[Música]
qué tal soy héctor será el profesor de
la facultad de filosofía de la
universidad panamericana y hoy quisiera
hablarles de algo muy importante la gran
empresa de nuestra vida nuestra propia
felicidad y les comienzo contando una
anécdota a mí me gusta mucho hablar de
comida me gusta comer me gusta ver
programas sobre comida y en una ocasión
vi uno de estos retos en donde varios
chefs de primer nivel enfrentaban el
reto consistía en que tenían un
presupuesto muy muy limitado y tenían
que entrar a una tienda de conveniencia
de estas de la esquina para dentro de
pocos minutos en pocos minutos comprar
los ingredientes necesarios
hacer la mejor cena posible contando
única y exclusivamente con los
ingredientes de esa tienda bueno la
verdad es que si a mí me llevan a una
tienda de estas se impone en ese reto
pues lo más que se me va a dar
seguramente es una sincronizada de jamón
queso y dos tortillas de harina si acaso
ya como muy muy creativo le pondrá unos
chiles jalapeños a mí me sorprendió lo
que hizo uno de los tres compro
tortillas de harina compro jamón
compro una manzana a veces hay manzanas
una manzana compro un aguardiente de
estos que toman mis estudiantes dicen
para las aguas locas que corriente
corriente y un poco de azúcar y entonces
lo que hizo fue colocar en las tortillas
de harina encima el jamón rebanar
finalmente las manzanas rociar la
disposi espolvorearlas con un poco de
azúcar muy poquita azúcar y luego
flamear todo con el aguardiente ese a mí
me sorprendió fue mejor que me
sincronizadas sin duda que es lo que
varió pues las habilidades que es lo que
tenía ese chef que no tenía yo si los
recursos eran los mismos las habilidades
y les cuento esto porque
viene a mi memoria algo que contaba
aristóteles en la ética a nicómaco
aristóteles decía que la vida es
el caso de un talabartero un zapatero al
que le envían un trozo de piel el no
puede decidir el trozo de piel la
calidad de la piel que va a trabajar y
tiene que sacar los mejores zapatos
posibles de ese trozo de piel un man
zapatero no podrá hacer nada cuando un
mal trozo de piel un mal zapatero
seguramente echará a perder un buen
trozo de piel un buen zapatero con una
piel
mala seguramente no conseguirá los
mejores zapatos pero algo conseguirá y
un trozo de piel buena para que el buen
zapatero tenga unos excelentes zapatos
es decir
la vida tiene unos aspectos que son como
son los griegos aristóteles decía algo
así como lo que está en mi poder efe min
hay algo que esté en mi poder y hay algo
que no está en mi poder y buena parte de
mi corporalidad del lugar donde nací y
mi edad hay un conjunto de
circunstancias que no dependen de mí
es son como el trozo de piel que me toca
o como el tener que ir a comprar
recursos productos a una tienda de
conveniencia
estoy limitada sin embargo decía
aristóteles lo que hemos de hacer es
concentrarnos en aquello que sí está en
nuestro poder es decir concentrarnos en
aquello que podemos controlar en lugar
de estarnos quejando en todos de todo
aquello que no podemos controlar
yo creo que esto viene muy a cuento hoy
por hoy con la pandemia la pandemia no
depende de nosotros pero sí depende de
nosotros el modo como enfrentemos la
pandemia y continuaba aristóteles y que
es lo más lo que depende de nosotros
pues algo sumamente importante nuestro
carácter
en otras palabras tenemos que hacernos
dueños de nosotros mismos a través de la
virtud que es la virtud la virtud son
esos hábitos esas habilidades a través
de las cuales nos hacemos dueño de
nuestras propias emociones y en la
medida que nos hacemos dueño de nosotros
mismos en la medida que nos controlamos
a nosotros mismos tenemos más
posibilidades de éxito en la vida esto
es muy importante porque a veces son las
emociones las que nos controlan y si las
emociones nos controlan
podemos tener casi la certeza es que nos
llevaremos a bueno y llegaremos a buen
puerto
déjenme decírselo en términos marineros
vayan vamos en un barco
el piloto o el capitán del barco no
puede controlar la intensidad de los
vientos no puede controlar el oleaje las
corrientes de agua que es lo que depende
del capitán depende el modo la habilidad
la inteligencia con que despliega las
velas y depende también la habilidad y
la fuerza de voluntad con que maneja el
timón claro si el capitán le toca
inicial va correcto cada una tempestad y
el capitán no tiene la fuerza de
voluntad suficiente como para resistir
en el timón a pesar de que esté
lloviendo a pesar de que hay un riesgo
para la propia vida
lo más probable es que el barco termine
hundiéndose en otras palabras hay dos
tipos de seres humanos aquellos que se
hacen dueños de sí mismos que forjan su
carácter a través de la virtud que se
adueñan de sus emociones y entonces esas
emociones
son utilizadas para impulsar al barco en
la dirección que yo quiero y aquellas
personas que por el contrario al no ser
dueñas de sus emociones que el barco va
siendo guiado se convierte en más que
hombres barcos diríamos que son hombres
veletas son personas cuyo carácter que
es frágil y es modelado por las
circunstancias mientras que hay otras
personas que siendo dueños de sí mismos
a través de la virtud pensaba
aristóteles con su carácter modelan las
circunstancias
por un lado tenemos entonces las
virtudes que nos morales que nos hacen
dueños de nosotros mismos pero también
hay otro otro aspecto de esta auto
posesión que es las habilidades
intelectuales también en el lenguaje
aristotélico se llamarían virtudes e
intelectuales que son el modo como
interpretamos el mundo que es en otras
palabras lo que depende de nosotros lo
que depende de nosotros en la vida es el
modo como interpretamos los hechos y el
modo como enfrentamos los sexos siendo
dueños de nosotros mismos
la ética les decía no es sino la
habilidad de ser felices de desplegar la
vida de la mejor manera posible de
llevar a una existencia plena en un
entorno incierto complejo creo que la
pandemia nos ha enseñado que la vida
puede cambiar en cuestión de meses en
cuestión de días en cuestión de semanas
la ética aristotélica
lo que nos enseña es a ser felices o es
una estrategia para ser felices en medio
de la incertidumbre por eso también me
gusta decir que la ética es la ética
aristotélica es sobre todo la
administración
de la incertidumbre y para administrar
la incertidumbre hace falta ser dueño de
nuestras emociones y ser hábiles
interpretar el mundo de la mejor manera
posible
me gustaría terminar simplemente con una
con una frase estoy re frase 'no una
oración que ustedes conocerán
a mí me gusta decir dios mío dame café
para cambiar aquello que puedo cambiar
dame whisky para aceptar aquello que no
puedo cambiar y dame chocolate para
poder ver la diferencia entre lo que si
puedo cambiar y lo que yo no puedo
cambiar yo soy héctor sara y recuerden
aquello que decía el man o el cant
sapere aude
atrévete a saber
[Música]